Queridos amigos, Javier Milei, el León
de la Argentina, ya es presidente.
(“Quiero decirles a todos los argentinos que
hoy comienza el fin de la decadencia argentina.
+
Hoy empezamos a dar
vuelta a la página de nuestra historia y volvemos
a retomar el camino que nunca deberíamos haber
perdido, hoy se termina el modelo empobrecedor
del Estado omnipresente que solo beneficia a
algunos mientras la mayoría de los
argentinos sufren”)
(“Hoy damos por terminada una larga y triste
historia de decadencia y declive. Y comenzamos el
camino de la reconstrucción de nuestro país. Los
argentinos de forma contundente han expresado una
voluntad de cambio que ya no tiene retorno. No hay
vuelta atrá, hoy enterramos décadas de fracaso.
No os quepa la menor duda, queridos
amigos, de que este nuevo presidente
nos dará mucho pero que mucho entretenimiento.
Tanto, que a este paso en VisualPolitik nos vamos
a tener que plantear seriamente mudarnos
a la propia Argentina, ¿no os parece?
El caso es que en vídeos anteriores
ya os hemos hablado de muchas de
las reformas que ha prometido Milei para
transformar de arriba abajo el país gaucho.
Sin embargo, su revolución
política no se queda solo en casa.
N1 (21 de noviembre de 2023: Pekín: sería "gran
error" para Milei cortar lazos con China. DW)
N2(29 de agosto de 2023: Lula sobre Javier Milei:
"Podría implicar un retroceso de 40 años". Ambito)
C1 (20 de noviembre de 2023: Ha ganado
la extrema derecha en Argentina;
es la decisión de su sociedad.
Triste para América Latina y ya
veremos... el neoliberalismo ya no
tiene propuesta para la sociedad,
no puede responder a los problemas actuales de la
humanidad. Gustavo Petro, presidente de Colombia)
C2 (20 de noviembre de 2023: Es un día
triste para el bloque democrático en todo
el mundo. Mucho ánimo al pueblo argentino que
hoy siente incertidumbre y miedo. Yolanda Díaz,
Vicepresidenta Segunda del Gobierno de España
y ministra de Trabajo y Economía Social.)
Milei no solo se ha convertido en un desafío
para todo el establishment local argentino,
sino también para muchos de los países
que han tratado de estrechar lazos con
la Casa Rosada en la última década.
Por eso, y dado que estamos en un canal
de política internacional, creo
que en esta ocasión tenemos que
responder a unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Cuáles será la política exterior de
Javier Milei? ¿Qué opinión tiene China
y EE. UU. de su llegada al poder? ¿Qué
intereses están en juego? ¿Llegaremos a
ver el Argexit del Mercosur? Pues bien,
Todo esto y más lo vamos a ver a continuación.
Gasolina y¡Arranquemos!
Buenos Aires es una ciudad tan
pasional como rebelde. Y, ojo,
no lo digo solo por el mundialmente conocido
carácter gaucho, sino también por la propia
política exterior de este país:
En los últimos 50 años Argentina
ha jugado en el mundo un rol de blanco o
negro, pero nunca una posición neutral.
Por ejemplo, en los 80s, en plena dictadura
militar, el régimen argentino se negó a sumarse
a los diferentes embargos de granos que EE.
UU. impulsó contra la URSS. Y eso a pesar de
que el dictador Videla y sus sucesores siempre
se jactaban de estar llevando a cabo una lucha
contra al “marxismo internacional”.
[Ya sabéis, cuestión de negocios.]
En esa misma etapa, Buenos Aires se metió, además,
en una guerra abierta contra el mismísimo Reino
Unido. Estamos por supuesto hablando de
la Guerra de Malvinas de 1983. Pero no
penséis que ahí termina todo: tan solo 7 años
después, ya en democracia, Argentina participó
activamente de la ejecución de las resoluciones
del Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU impulsadas
por EE. UU. contra Irak en 1990. Vale, no es que
tuviera una contribución relevante, pero apoyó
la guerra y envío 1 destructor y 3 corbetas a
la zona para hacer operaciones de patrullaje.
Posteriormente, hacia 2005, Néstor Kirchner,
como anfitrión de la Cumbre de las Américas,
celebrada en Mar del Plata, fue uno de los líderes
políticos que acabaron con el ALCA, el “Área de
Libre Comercio de las Américas” que proponía EE.
UU. Una de las grandes iniciativas de George Bush.
(“Aquí en Mar del Plata está
la tumba del alca. Alca,
alca, al carajo.” Hugo Chávez, presidente)
(“¿Por qué no quieren tener acceso al mercado de
Estados Unidos? Los acuerdos comerciales reducen
los aranceles y las barreras. Eso es lo que hacen.
Por eso tenemos acuerdos de libre comercio. No lo
hacen más difícil, sino que facilitan el acceso
al mercado. ¿Y por qué alguien no querría
acceder a nuestro mejor mercado? No lo sé.)
Argentina quizás no es una potencia militar,
ni tampoco un enclave geopolítico esencial,
ni un emirato petrolero – aunque ojo
con Vaca Muerta - pero de una forma
u otra siempre se las arregla para estar
metido en todos los follones de la región.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Parece que eso no cambiará mucho
con la llegada de Javier Milei a la Casa Rosada:
(estamos
trabajando en armar una estrategia para
enfrentar la izquierda a nivel
internacional y una de las posibilidades
que también estamos elaborando es la
posibilidad de hacer una suerte de
congreso de la derecha digamos entendída
en el sentido como se piensa en términos
políticos en Argentina)
En cualquier caso, sea como sea, Argentina
es el segundo país más grande de Sudamérica,
con una relevante proyección territorial sobre
la Antártida, y un cúmulo de rutas marítimas
entre los océanos Atlántico Sur y Pacífico Sur,
tales como el estrecho de Magallanes, Canal
de Beagle el Pasaje de Drake, que hacen que
su posición internacional tenga cierto interés.
Algo que por cierto explica noticias como estas:
N3 (El Comando Sur de Estados Unidos alertó por
la base espacial china en Argentina. Perfil)
Luego hablaremos de esto.
Pero por ahora la pregunta es,
¿qué significa exactamente la llegada de
Milei a la presidencia? ¿Quiénes serán
sus aliados y sus enemigos en el escenario
internacional? ¿Qué podemos esperar de él?
Pues bien… Atentos.
¿SE VIENE EL REARME ARGENTINO?
qué? Nunca está de más ponernos en situación:
En Argentina, las FFAA son un tema delicado.
Esto es así porque durante el
siglo XX, entre 1930 y 1976,
los militares dieron 6 golpes de Estado, cerrando
el ciclo burocrático militar en 1983, con miles de
desaparecidos y una dolorosa derrota bélica.
Esta situación hizo que en democracia
la relación entre los civiles y los
militares fuese relativamente tensa:
no tengo miedo
ni les tengo miedo
queremos el ejército de San Martín
Belgrano, Mosconi y Sabio
y no de aquellos que asesinaron a sus
propios hermanos, que fueron de
Videla, Galtieri,
Viola y Bignone)
Desde los años 90s, una forma
de debilitar la posición de los
uniformados fue recortar su presupuesto. Fijaos.
(Hacia 1988, en la última etapa del gobierno de
Raúl Alfonsín, Argentina era uno de los países con
mayor gasto militar per cápita de toda la región,
pero ahora es el peor en esta categoría. La
diferencia, por ejemplo, con Chile es enorme.)
Por supuesto, con la que está cayendo en Argentina
no parece que las fuerzas armadas puedan ni deban
ser una prioridad. Sin embargo, pese a todo,
en 2020 el el gobierno de Alberto Fernández
creo el Fondo Nacional de la Defensa.
Este fondo tiene como objetivo financiar
el reequipamiento de las Fuerzas Armadas
argentinas, con un capital fijo mínimo del
0,8% del Presupuesto Público Anual. Hablamos de
al menos unos 800 millones de dólares por año.
¿Y qué piensa sobre este el nuevo presidente?
Pues lo cierto es que Javier Milei está a favor
de la modernización y actualización
del equipamiento militar argentino:
El factor moral de las
fuerzas está fuertemente afectado. El
personal sufre una acentuada frustración
vocacional luego de años de agravios.
por eso proponemos crear un
instrumento militar ágil moderno y
tecnológicamente avanzado que reemplace
las actuales estructuras obsoletas,
financiar adecuadamente la defensa
nacional para revertir el deficiente
estado de equipamiento e instrucción.)
Así que ya lo veis, las fuerzas armadas son
uno de esos raras avis donde parece existir
un gran consenso entre los políticos argentinos.
El problema es… ¿Quién será el proveedor de
los nuevos equipos? Ojo con esta pregunta.
Por ejemplo, los planes actuales contemplan
la compra de lanchas de patrullaje,
la modernización de vehículos mecanizados,
así como la adquisición de nuevos radares
y diversos tipos de munición. Sin embargo,
el plato más jugoso está en el cielo:
La modernización de los aviones de combate.
(Argentina quiere modernizar sus viejos
cazas, que en su mayoría forman parte
de generaciones utilizadas durante la guerra de
Malvinas. Y mira que ha llovido desde entonces.
En este sentido, el gobierno de Alberto Fernández
recibió varias ofertas: las dos principales tienen
que ver con los JF 17 Thunder chino, y los F16
norteamericanos. En este último caso F-16 de
segunda mano que podrían proceder de Dinamarca.
Naturalmente, ahora que conocemos las opciones
podemos comprender perfectamente el trasfondo
geopolítico que esta decisión conlleva.
Pensad que cada una de estas ofertas no
solo comprende el propio avión de combate,
sino también sus repuestos, simuladores,
misiles y el entrenamiento militar. Es decir,
hablamos de un paquete que por sí mismo podría
vincular a largo plazo a la fuerza aérea argentina
con Estados Unidos, China o la India.)
Pues bien, en la 63 de la Conferencia
de los jefes de las Fuerzas Aéreas de América ,
que tuvo lugar el pasado mes de julio de 2023,
los comandantes de las alas argentinas mostraron
abiertamente su preferencia por los F16.
Y en octubre Washington dio
su visto bueno a la operación:
N4 (11 de octubre de 2023: Estados Unidos
autorizó una venta de aviones F-16 a la Argentina
El Departamento dio luz verde para realizar
una transferencia de 24 aeronaves de Dinamarca;
la transacción compite con una
oferta de China. La Nación)
El problema para la compra de muchos equipos
occidentales tiene que ver por Londres.
C3 (“La resistencia del Reino Unido a la
modernización y el avance militar argentinos
puso a Argentina en manos de China. Argentina
se comprometió con China en 2021 a evaluar los
cazas JF-17 chino-pakistaníes. Los JF-17 son
asequibles y de gran valor para Argentina,
principalmente porque no están
sujetos a las sanciones del
Reino Unido.” To Counter China in Latin
America, Focus on Argentina - U.S. Naval
Institute | Captain Frank Okata, U.S. Navy)
Y es que veréis, el embargo que UK mantiene sobre
la comercialización de armas a la Argentina
limita las aspiraciones de la Casa Rosada.
De no levantar Londres, su bloqueo, ningún
equipo, militar, podrían tener componentes
británicos… Y el problema es que hay
algunos equipos que sí los tienen.
Por eso, la Casa Blanca está intentando triangular
un acuerdo entre el 10 de Downing
Street y la Casa Rosada para evitar
que la opción china sea al final la más
viable a la hora de comprar armamento.
Sea como sea, parece que al final la opción
de los F-16 daneses de segunda mano será la
preferida… Ya sabéis que Milei ha dicho por activa
y por pasiva, que el nuevo presidente argentino no
estará dispuesto bajo ningún concepto a vincularse
militarmente con la República Popular China.
[Claro que veremos si finalmente se
compran. Tal y como se encuentran
las finanzas argentinas… ¿Qué queréis qué os
diga? El gasto militar no parece una prioridad]
En cualquier caso no se trata solo de los
aviones. A medio y largo plazo, la elección
del proveedor militar preferente tendrá muchas
implicaciones políticas. Por supuesto, China
quiere quedarse con ese puesto a toda costa.
¿Pero sabéis qué? La llegada de Milei no solo
parece enviar al traste esa posibilidad,
sino que además es posible que estemos ante
la mejor oportunidad para que en cierta forma
se alivie la tensión que todavía existe entre
Londres y Buenos Aires. Fijaos en esta noticia:
N5 (Diana Mondino, sobre Malvinas: “Los isleños
tienen los mismos derechos que cualquier
argentino, negar eso es ridículo”. Clarin)
Diana Mondino no es cualquier voz, es la nueva
ministra de asuntos exteriores de Milei.
Y es que ya no solo hablamos de un tema económico,
sino de un tema geopolítico. Reino Unido
sigue siendo sumamente estricto con el embargo
post-malvinas contra la Argentina. Milei ha dejado
claro que no mantendrá relaciones proactivas con
China, con lo que su inclinación por el armamento
occidental es algo que se da por hecho.
¿Mejorarán las cosas lo suficiente entre
Londres y Buenos Aíres para que eso
sea posible? Desde luego podemos
estar ante la mejor oportunidad desde 1982.
Sea como sea, este tema va mucho más allá…
Aunque sea por otros caminos. Amigos, Buenos Aires
se encuentra ahora entre Pekín y de Washington.
Atentos.
(T2: CUENTOS CHINOS Y LA SOMBRA DE TRUMP)
Queridos amigos, la cruzada de Javier Milei
contra la casta trasciende fronteras. En el
exterior ya ha dejado claro que el comunismo
será su gran enemigo. La llegada de Milei a
la Casa Rosada parece volar en mil pedazos
las relaciones tanto con Rusia como con China.
¿Y sabéis qué? En lo que respecta al gigante
asiático, son muchos los intereses que están
en riesgo: en los últimos años la vinculación
de China con Argentina ha sido clave para
su desembarco en América Latina. Fijaos.
(23 de mayo 2022: El abrazo de Argentina a
China debería ser una llamada de atención
Argentina es un ejemplo paradigmático de
cómo América Latina se está orientando
hacia el Este para satisfacer sus necesidades
económicas y de desarrollo, lo que posiblemente
la encamine hacia una trayectoria centrada en
China en los años venideros. ForeignPolicy)
N7 (6 de febrero de 2022: Argentina se
sumó a la Nueva Ruta de la Seda y obtiene
un millonario financiamiento.
Con esta decisión estratégica,
el gobierno nacional rubricará diferentes
acuerdos que garantizan financiamiento para
inversiones y obras por más de 23.700 millones de
dólares, generando un nuevo hito en la relación
bilateral que en los últimos 15 años se
amplió y fortaleció notablemente. Telam)
De hecho, la cooperación entre ambos países llegó
a tal punto, que, en agosto de 2022, se filtró un
memorándum entre el gobierno provincial de
Tierra del Fuego y la empresa china Shaanxi
Chemical Industry Group para la construcción de
un polo petroquímico que contara con una “terminal
portuaria multipropósito”.
Además, China mantiene en
Argentina, en la provincia de provincia
del Neuquén, la Estación de Espacio Lejano.
Desde esta estación, los gobiernos de Argentina
y la República Popular China brindan soporte de
telemetría, seguimiento, control de
las misiones del Programa Chino para
Exploración de la Luna y varios otros programas
de investigación científica sobre el espacio.
La relevancia de este tipo de programas
ha estado incrementándose tanto que
China ya resalta su papel a nivel oficial.
Lo de Pekín y Buenos Aires era un romance en
ascenso, que ya hacía ruido hasta en Londres:
C4(“Argentina es una de las muchas piezas del
plan chino para Sudamérica. China pretende
desarrollar una base militar en Bata,
Guinea Ecuatorial. Bata comparte las mismas
ventajas que Ascensión tuvo para el Reino
Unido durante la guerra de las Malvinas.
Una cooperación más estrecha entre China y
Argentina permitirá a la Armada del Ejército
Popular de Liberación (PLAN) imponer mayores
costes de defensa al Reino Unido para defender
las Malvinas, lo que podría alejar a su naciente
fuerza de portaaviones de ataque y submarinos
del apoyo a las operaciones de Estados Unidos,
la OTAN y el Indo-Pacífico.” To Counter China in
Latin America, Focus on Argentina - U.S. Naval
Institute | Captain Frank Okata, U.S. Navy)
Pero queridos amigos, ahora el amor está a
punto de llegar a su final. Milei ha dejado claro
que alineará su política con EE. UU. e Israel,
y que enfriará e, incluso, romperá
relaciones con gobiernos “comunistas”.
Claro que tampoco es que le caiga
particularmente bien la actual
Administración de Joe Biden Fijaos lo que
decía cuando está llegó a la Casa Blanca.
los demócratas
empezaron a buscar censurar antes de
ingresar ahora hablan de perseguir a los
libertarios porque son inadaptados
que no les gusta el estado)
Y desde luego, ya os digo yo
que el sentimiento es recíproco.
En Washington muchos ven a Milei como una
especie de Little Trump, entre otras cosas,
porque muchos medios norteamericanos y varios
políticos republicanos se han encargado de forjar
esa imagen pese a todas las diferencias políticas
que existen entre Milei y Trump y de las que ya
os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik.
N8 (14 de agosto de 2023: Un libertario
de extrema derecha gana las primarias
presidenciales en Argentina. NY Times)
N9 (18 de agosto de 2023: Los republicanos
descubren al libertario Milei y Ted Cruz lo
promueve como ejemplo para los candidatos
de su partido. La Política Online)
Por si fuera poco, en 2021 el mismo Milei
respaldaba las tesis del fraude electoral y
justificaba el asalto al Capitolio en Washington:
hay muchos
testimonios de que digamos
hubo ciertas irregularidades y por algo
la gente está así no es que digamos o
sea esto no es que fue organizado dio
para que la gente vaya de sodio la gente
cuando se siente estafada digamos actúa
de manera que uno no lo puede explicar)
Así que tampoco es que en el Washington
actual Milei vaya a encontrar muchos
amigos. Es posible que lo vean como
un mal menor frente a China. Pero la
relación probablemente no vaya mucho más allá-
Claro que si hablamos de política exterior y
Milei tenemos que hablar sobre todo
y por encima de todo de Mercosur.
¿Qué por qué? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(T3: ARGEXIT: ¿EL FIN DEL MERCOSUR?)
Desde los años 90s Argentina está comprometida
con el Mercado Común del Sur, Mercosur,
una unión aduanera en la que también encontramos
a Brasil, Uruguay y Paraguay. Mercosur es una
organización que, todo sea dicho, tras
tres décadas funcionando no ha dado los
frutos que se esperaban ni de lejos.
Mercosur ha sido incapaz de avanzar en
la liberalización del comercio. Ni siquiera
ha podido eliminar aranceles internos así
que imaginaos el desastre que es cuando
hablamos del resto del mundo. De hecho,
muchas veces más que una organización
pro-comercio es una organización anti-comercio.
Por ejemplo, Mercosur ha impedido que por ahora
sus países miembros puedan firmar acuerdos de
libre comercio con terceros países. Que es, por
ejemplo, lo que Uruguay quiere hacer con China.
Pues bien, con semejante escenario, el plan
motosierra de Milei pretende no abrir un debate
dentro de Mercosur para intentar reformarlo poco
a poco, sino plantear su directa eliminación.
yo creo que hay que
eliminar el Mercosur porque es una Unión
aduanera defectuosa que perjudica a los
argentinos de bien o sea es en el fondo
es un comercio administrado por Estados
para favorecer empresarios prebendarios)
Y es que el problema que tienen los
libertarios con Mercosur no solo se
limita a una cuestión económica o comercial,
sino que también afecta al propio debate
ideológico que plantea la Libertad Avanza.
Para Milei, cualquier acercamiento a gobiernos
socialistas es inaceptable, por lo que compartir
bloque y tener que negociar y pactar con el
Brasil de Lula no estaría dentro de sus planes.
yo soy un defensor de la Libertad
de la paz y de la democracia
los comunistas no entran ahí los
chinos no entran ahí Putin no entra ahí
digamos Lula no entra ahí es decir
nosotros queremos ser el faro
moral del continente)
Quizás al final pase lo mismo que con
Bulrrich, al fin y al cabo hablamos de un
mercado importante para Argentina. De dos mercados
importantes si también tenemos en cuenta a China.
(Entre el 30% y 25% de todas las exportaciones
argentinas tienen como destino el Mercosur o
China. Y si bien los vínculos podrían
proseguir con el sector privado, romper
los acuerdos vigentes en el Mercosur obligaría
a llevar a cabo toda una restructuración de los
trámites y procesos comerciales que, seguro,
entorpecerá los flujos comerciales durante un
tiempo. Y respecto a China, bueno, ya sabéis
lo aficionados que son en Pekín a castigar el
comercio con aquellos países que no le son leales.
Es lo que se llama la política del lobo guerrero
de la que ya os hemos hablado en VisualPolitik)
Sea como sea ojo con que Milei cumpla su palabra.
Claro que, insisto, también puede ocurrir
que pase lo mismo que con Bulrrich...
Que de ser casta y ser una montonera
tirabombas paso a ser una fiel aliada.
Al fin y al cabo, tanto Macri como
Bolsonaro tuvieron buenas relaciones
tanto con Washington como con Moscú y
Pekín. [Pragmatismo por encima de todo]
¿Hará lo mismo Milei y se marcará un Pedro
Sánchez? Ya sabéis eso de “cambié de opinión?
De momento, Milei ha prometido ser tajante
con este tema. Y de hecho ha dejado muy
claro que se retirará de los BRICS.
N10 (Javier Milei también rechazó el
ingreso de Argentina a los
BRICS: “No voy a impulsar
un trato con comunistas”. Clarin)
Desde luego si mantiene su palabra…
Milei puede sembrar todo un precedente.
No está claro si para bien o para mal…
Pero sería algo completamente nuevo.
Amigos, si algo está claro es que fuera
de Argentina, La Libertad Avanza y
Milei no dejan indiferentes a nadie:
o lo aman o lo odian. Ni siquiera el Papa,
que es argentino, escapa a esta cruzada:
ha sido un Papa donde tiene
fuerte injerencia política
ha demostrado además una
gran afinidad con dictadores)
Así que ya lo veis. Podemos esperar una
Argentina mucho más volcada a Occidente.
Pero hay muchos temas que veremos a ver cómo
se resuelven. Si Milei cumple su palabra,
creo que va a dar mucho de qué hablar también en
lo que respecta a su política exterior.
En VisualPolitik estaremos muy atentos.
Pero ahora turno para ti:
Ahora es turno para ti: ¿Qué te parece la postura
que hasta ahora ha tenido Milei? ¿Crees que la
mantendrá en la Casa Rosada? ¿Qué harías tu?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y abramos debate.
Y por supuesto, si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante,
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.